même s'il tombe tu vas où tu abuses
kader tup attention sécurité obligatoire
sur ce chantier nature une dizaine
d'adolescents coupes et des broussailles
ce plateau calcaire du site de la grotte
ici on allie l'utile à l'agréable matin
on travaille puis après midi on a des
activités on est libre donc c'est bien
j'ai appris des choses sur les papillons
et les libellules que je ne savais pas
avec faust âge a pris les choses par
rapport comment différencier un mâle et
une femelle chez les arcs et identifier
les espèces et comprendre la spécificité
du milieu naturel qu'ils entretiennent
durant le séjour
c'est l'enjeu de ce camp ils créent
parfois même des vocations
plus tard je voudrais faire un métier un
peu dans ce domaine a justement un petit
peu comme sébastien chargé de mission et
du coup ça va intéresser ça faisait
longtemps que j'en cherchais un jeu
regrette pas d'y être venu puisque j'ai
appris les choses et puis samaha sam
approfondies et des méconnaissances puis
ça me donne encore plus envie de faire
ce que ce que je voulais faire plus tard
c'est très important je trouve de
sensibiliser mais rien que juste
s'émerveiller au delà d'être spécialiste
c'est vraiment juste apprendre à
observer autour de chez soi et apprendre
à respecter et dire souvent à la
remarque à quoi ça sert mais ça sert
toujours ça dépend la vision après qu'on
a
observez et respecter son environnement
tout un programme
comme le sauvetage de cette mante
religieuse du débroussaillage
un geste qui résume à lui seul la
philosophie du camp